[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week welcome welcome to this edition of
bone head of the week
we are in some sort of parallel universe
where gabe sanchez is here but he's not
here
it's i think it's called recording is
what it is it's a
soros feature yes it is
a.i ai gabe is what this is no i'm just
kidding we're recording this in advance
but um you guys know that because you
voted early this week we had the poll
out on twitter
at tony michael's pod
go follow us on twitter you can vote
there you can also vote for us here on
youtube at the tony michaels pod so if
you are over on the midas touch network
channel come over and follow us on toni
michael 5 watch us live
bonehead of the week every single friday
in the second hour
and if you're on the minus touch network
right now go ahead and click that
subscribe button there as well welcome
to bone end of the week no matter where
you're watching
it is all recorded this week but that's
okay
gabe's got important deep state bunker
work to do i think
what's going on deep deep deep state
deep underground deep underground bunker
work deep deep so like soros has me on
uh
not just a tip like all the way all the
way all the way
good just
oh okay good good good well we have we
have a bunch of
the dick talk we have a lot of dicks to
get to ah this week at bone end of the
week who's our contestants here gabe
holy moly we gotta know we got some
[ __ ] boneheads here we got mike
lindell holy [ __ ]
graham yeah rudy kaluti my hair's
draining giuliani grandpa farty mcshardy
rudy giuliani as i call him yeah what a
great set of boneheads this week i'm
excited we have we also have a special
alpha cuck
and and a dishonorable mention he's
pretty much always a dishonorable
mention yeah just sometimes other people
work their way up ahead of him yeah yeah
yeah sometimes they're kind of hateable
yeah
usually just like by a smidge that
they're like oh this guy is even more of
an [ __ ] right because this guy every
week could be on this list or dm
alphagek i mean this guy
everybody hates him like everybody i
mean i think even his daughters hate him
right his dog has to definitely oh yeah
and the cat hates him even worse but
let's get to our our original
contestants rudy colludi grandpa party
mccarty rudy giuliani is on the list
gabe
did he say something about september
11th is that why he's on the list this
week is that yeah what's going on
america's mayor
said that uh september 11th was one of
the greatest i think is what he said it
was one of the greatest moments
of his life now i remember i actually
think i actually which is definitely a
take on definitely
a take
he's something he's something um when he
says when he says that uh it's the best
day in the worst day and i remember this
uh this video because
he said this on september 11th right he
was being interviewed um of course uh
they were talking about september 11th
uh let me see if i can uh find this
great piece of tape i'm like i i i
imagine that prepared but when i heard
rudy say this i was like oh this is is
this like charles dickens like it was
the best of times it was the worst times
like rudy giuliani's just giving i think
it was oan that he was on or something
like that wow that's one of the
oh looky here we got the tweet here it's
actually from our page the tony podcast
um you can follow us at the tony
michaels podcast because we bring you
the breaking news there we hold the
media
accountable my rudy giuliani describes 9
11
as the greatest day of his life that was
what i don't i think i wrote that i'm
not sure yeah no that was the right yeah
you wrote that yeah it looks like my
kind of tweet what are you trying to say
what are you no no i mean i probably
would have said the same thing oh okay
you know just maybe not the eye or
something yeah i don't know maybe like
that awkward like
yeah that could be well i mean that's
kind of what he looks like here yeah
yeah the smashed face the drunk face but
of course you see the live shot of the
freedom tower here um where the twin
towers once stood
so it it's and this is september 11th so
i think they're probably going to be
asking him
about
oh they're going to ask him about
september 11 he's going to say something
stupid listen i mean i guess the best
way to describe it is it was the worst
day of my life yeah
and in some ways you know the greatest
day of my life in terms of
my city
my country my family
i mean what in the [ __ ]
it was the worst day of his life i mean
i completely understand that right
yeah oh yeah i mean it was it was a it
was the country's worst day it's like
when he says it's easy to say that it's
easy to say that september 11th even if
you weren't in new york like whoa that
was one of the worst days in my
country's modern day i mean i remember
where i was when the when when the
planes hit the tower where were you
where were you i was going to school and
then we were everyone was at school and
then it was a lot of people i remember
that my classmates were really worried
because i had a couple friends their
their parents worked in the sears tower
which is now known as wills tower right
but they were one of the oh we're
evacuating we're doing this so i mean
nobody had class pretty much like you
went from class to class and it was just
like uh we're not going to do anything
kind of day like it was one of those
moments where i will never forget and
i'm sure you will never forget no i i
well i'll tell you that um so i i was in
the midwest so there's not a lot of tall
buildings i mean you know the tall
building to us is like three or four
stories like whoa that's a big ass
building but i mean we didn't have tall
buildings so when i heard this
i was sitting in art class i remember it
um
and the the the kid that said it out
loud
he's actually passed away now but i
remember him saying it
like i remember it exiting his mouth he
said yeah they flew those planes into
those towers now when you're in the
midwest there's there's towers but
they're like cell phone and radio tower
right right right there's not big tall
buildings
so what i thought was like a little
bitty plane flew into one of those
towers when he said it originally
and we started to talk about he said no
no the ones in new york the uh the the
twin towers
so
that's when we were like whoa what the
hell and our art teacher turned it on
the radio because we didn't have a tv in
the classroom so she turned it on the
radio
and like
about
it wasn't much long after that when
the the plane had flew into the pentagon
and we listened to that reporting live
on the air on the radio right um and i
remember
that so vividly the reason why is
because the assistant principal's office
her office was very close to the art
room
and um when that news broke
you could hear her exit her office
very fast she was very erratic and she
was screaming running down the hall
we're being attacked we're being
attacked we're being gagged because
um you know the first and second tower
there's a lot of speculation but when
the pentagon right had been hit
everyone really that was the thing that
everyone really knew yeah that wow this
really is this is real this is something
really they're attacking our country
they're not just attacking new york
they're coming after our government our
way of life and they're terrorists and
they're i mean even the people that were
in new york who were there downtown in
manhattan didn't even know what was
going on at the time like you know
because it was so quick
you know that the first plane entered
and was like wait what what's going on
you know and then you know then later
everyone's seeing the second plane and
being like oh [ __ ] okay something's
going on right exactly and it is one of
those things that even for the people
that were there you know didn't know i
mean let alone us in the midwest at the
time we were like we don't really know
we don't understand i mean i think we
caught some of like the today show where
they covered it moments later and
they're like
holy [ __ ] like what's right what's going
on well because because that day i mean
um
you know it kind of continued on that
day
um you know because it wasn't just that
moment but it affected the entire
country
forever really i mean we're still paying
some of those for some of those things
then that we did you know the stuff that
we didn't know then that we do know now
we're still paying the price for some of
those things but i mean
um i even remember
i had a history class and he was one of
the only teachers that had cable tv in
his room um lucky him but um he had the
news on and we actually watched um one
of the towers fall on live tv oh wow
which is really weird um especially for
a bunch of country bumpkins who
some of them had never even seen
that big of a building in real life and
to watch one of them fall on live tv was
some was really you know something and
we couldn't even imagine what it would
be like to be there yeah um you know
and i think
um
now some of the things that we know
about the first responders
about the the the cops the firefighters
um who were there
and you hear some of those stories and
it's it's heartbreaking so to hear rudy
giuliani
even utter the words because i know what
he's saying here he's saying it was
great for me and my political career
right right i became america's mayor i
was the one who you know i mean like
he's also the guy that was like i never
saw hillary clinton down there in the
rubble and there's literally a photo
with hillary clinton and next with him
right they were there together right so
obviously you know he politicizes it and
and tries to use that as political like
collateral and in clout and say i was
the one who helped rebuild a city that
was attacked from something that is
unfortunate
anyways well the other thing too that i
think
you know because
at the time everyone was like oh my god
rudy giuliani's so great right because
he was the mayor and he did you know
there was this sense
in our country that this disaster had
happened and it happened to us as
americans and we were all together in
this
the same way you would expect that we
would have came together during the
pandemic but it was the opposite right
um you know we we should have came
together and we should have said this is
a national crisis it is killing
thousands of americans and we should all
band together to prevent this death from
happening even if our enemy is some
invisible virus and not
a you know
an ideology that has infected people's
minds right that are willing to commit
violence on us like ideology has
affecting terrorists in our country now
i mean we we watch this week as a guy
dressed in with a clown wig and a safety
vest goes into a dairy queen and he's
gonna kill democrats and liberals and
make donald trump the president king of
the united states i'm not making that
[ __ ] up yeah that is under undercover
right undercover i use a lot of air
quotes today but that's what they are
right i mean they're actually used
correctly here but yeah undercover to to
bring
donald trump back as the king and you
know i know that we joke about it all
the time but i mean like it's also the
language that they use whether it was
january 6th it was don jr it's any of
their like marketing or ways that
they'll send you emails or texts that
it's like hey
make sure to donate to the mega king
donald trump you say it enough times and
people believe you that's the way that
this person should be referred to so
like you've got a crazy guy in clown
that go clown you know
uh costume or mask that goes into a
dairy queen a [ __ ] dairy queen like
where you go get a blizzard right and he
goes in there with guns and you know
tries to like of all places dairy
queen's gonna play be the place that
he's gonna reinstate trump it's right
that is the insanity i don't think it's
supposed to make sense just like it
doesn't make sense to fly planes in the
buildings right right and a lot of
people are going to say oh tony and gabe
you're being [ __ ] comparing those
terrorists to maga supporters
um i don't think it's too far of a
stretch folks yeah i don't think it's
too far of a stretch when when you watch
that they're believing in right-wing
ideology
and not only are they believing in it
the delusion of it but they're acting it
out in violent ways like an insurrection
like going to an fbi headquarters with a
staple gun and a and a firearm like
going the dairy queen with a firearm
and these these instances keep happening
and they keep threatening online and and
you have
the actual leaders the politicians
making tapes of themselves saying this
stuff it sounds familiar it sounds like
um what's that group that flew planes
into buildings i'm just saying right
that that it is the same it doesn't
matter if if you're if it's a different
religion if it's a different country and
you're a different race it doesn't
matter it's the same [ __ ] it's the same
[ __ ] and we should be vigilant and [ __ ]
rudy giuliani to be quite honest he can
[ __ ] all the way off i mean that was i
mean him saying that was incredibly
disgusting and so
so uncalled for because like you know
then you got to think
how do the families feel right all of
the people that experience trauma from
the people from those that they lost or
survivors that have trauma and ptsd the
people or even the first responders
his comment
is so
uh
so gross
and disgusting and violent it's good for
me politically it made me who i am today
you're a piece of [ __ ] you can you can
feel that rudy you're not supposed to
say that quiet part out loud dummy right
speaking of people who say the quiet
part out loud
holy [ __ ] mike lindell cannot shut the
[ __ ] up gabe oh boy he cannot shut up
um
so we know now that he was
he was stopped at a hardy's
drive-through yeah he was getting
whatever
you know this is the question i've got
this question from people they're like
well is it the same cell phone that he
had two years ago that doesn't make
sense i'm like look
you know when you go get an iphone and
you buy a new iphone
you know the procedure you do a backup
on the old phone and you download that
to the new phone just like you did the
last three times so all the last three
cell phones
are all now on that phone that is how it
works yeah this that is how it works i
mean the only difference is they're just
milestones of like all right here's all
the terrible things that i did or said
here here's all the crimes i've given it
on my iphone
nine yeah and then there was the 10 and
the 11. and each part it shows you phase
by phase of how i was a a traitorous uh
terrible human on which iphone yeah yeah
still see how he evolved you know right
through through his different he became
a better treasonous piece of [ __ ] as the
phones got better
it is true they were better at at
plotting a coup
as they got newer editions of the iphone
but
that's what my first thought was is of
course it's the old iphone because
that's the first thing you do i mean
literally mike lindell would have to
chuck his old iphone into the ocean and
then and then go get a brand new iphone
and start from scratch but he couldn't
do that gabe because he's running like
35 000 businesses right that's what he
says
that's what he that's what he said last
night twitter
doesn't make a lot of sense though when
you i mean when you begin to fact check
and say hey is there any truth to what
you're saying i mean look i can only
trust mike lindell as far as or or as
comfortable as his pillows are which
obviously as anyone knows are [ __ ]
[ __ ] so they're not very they're not
very comfortable so i don't trust the
guy right
but when he was talking last night he
started saying some things i was like oh
wait i remember that name or oh wait i
remember uh that sounds familiar right
and he starts talking about tina peters
and some other people that were on this
document as other [ __ ]
co-conspirators right
well i've got i've got video evidence
here that he's got more than one phone
oh yeah this is this is the best at to
date
this is the best mike glendale content
that exists anywhere on the internet is
this video right here uh for all you who
don't know which if you haven't seen
this where the hell have you been
sleeping underneath my pillow um this is
uh we figured that out this is in a
courtyard in san diego right yeah that's
the hotel that's what
that's what some people commented on the
video when i shared it okay so
if you look here this
right here this little this feller here
who um
looks like michael and delphi how is he
so recognizable even from the back
he just has that like a block head you
know is that what it is i just feel like
he just has that
you don't need to see him from the front
to just know like oh that's that's
lindell vibes right there right right it
really does look like he even sleeps on
one of his shitty pillows uh just by his
posture and stuff on the chair but you
can see here he's got a phone that he's
talking into
but on the table gabe there's another
phone there right so that guy's got that
two
so he doesn't have one he's got one and
another one right he's got two in this
video at least so this i mean this is
simple math anyone can do this math and
follow along one wow one i mean besides
people who can't count votes right no
yeah well you know but let's watch
because there's a surprise in this video
for people who haven't seen it now
everyone who has seen it you're not
gonna you're not gonna be sad because
this is the greatest content that the
internet can possibly produce here so we
could watch this every single day and
still love this video so watch
this
because we are direct
so we don't have that now
so he's live on tv right yeah so he's
talking live
just like we do why would you not do
this you're in the you're in a hotel
courtyard why would you not do this in
your actual room
well i mean it depends on what the
room's like and what you did the night
before in there i mean
you know okay who knows who knows what
that what the condition of mike
lindell's room is but of all places i
mean a public courtyard it's already
noisy enough i mean i get that he's got
the airpods in but like come on man come
on you really think that this mustache
mussolini has any kind of brain to
realize that he probably shouldn't do it
in a public courtroom but gabe there's
something else about this video yeah
it's not just in a public courtyard now
he is in a public courtyard
but watch this watch this fight man keep
fighting don't don't let the lip tarps
call
does he have pants on
looks like he's either wearing shorts or
underwear
those are boxer shorts the dude the dude
didn't even put pants on to go in the
corner this is a typical routine that
you would find uh working from home
right during the pandemic and when
you're in quarantine you have meetings
boom right business
does not gabe does not wear pants on a
show i don't wear pants right now i got
a shirt and i'm just nothing underneath
you know
so i mean for those watching we're not
going to click on normal right now
that's the difference i will do that in
the privacy of my own home i will not do
that onto others in a public courtyard
at a hotel you're saying you won't do a
tubing on the on the uh on the tube no
no no no no no
definitely not in public and no lindelin
in the courtyard now there's more
there's more than just this tape because
he got his phone seized which one am i
looking at here for the uh i think it's
the second one here is the is where
where he went on what is it called
lindell tv what is his friends i can't
figure out what the [ __ ] this is frank
speech.com is the is the umbrella okay
and on frank speech.com he's got
lindell tv
okay lindell tv is the tv network
so that's not the show nope nope nope
not the show and then he's got the
lindell report now that is a show
okay so it's frank speech
tv
lindell
tv well no no no no no no no no no no
yeah so
calm lindell tv the lindell report so
you just got to kind of
come down a little bit where are you
where do you watch this garbage because
you watched it so we don't have to right
yeah yeah you can watch it at
frankspeach.com
so you're welcome no don't don't go
whatever you do
don't go you probably would be able to
find this stuff on rumble.com as well
but the main source of this content is
on
frankspeach.com well here's the thing
you can just go subscribe to the tony
michaels podcast on twitter on youtube
stay tuned there we will try to bring
you the relevant crazy ass mike lindell
clips that way you don't have to watch
it
um
but here is
now this is a little different clip than
what most people are watching this is
one you posted
on twitter but i think this is him this
is him
starting the story off they said like oh
yeah we're driving through iowa coming
back home or whatever i was hunting and
this is when he gets to the whole like
how he was or where he was confronted
when they found out that he was criming
well they didn't find out they just went
to get the evidence that he was criming
because that's the real thing here that
that these [ __ ] aren't really talking
about is they're like he can't take a
cell phone it's illegal that no it's not
not when they improbable cause what are
you talking about
if they have problems
based on the evidence they have to say
hey look crimes were committed it's the
same [ __ ] that people say oh
president trump's home in mar-a-lago
should have been raided well it turns
out that a federal judge said oh yeah
this actually does make sense and you
should act on it right now so i will
sign off on this warrant and that's what
people need to realize you know what i'm
just thinking this so if if the fbi can
go and they have probable cause that you
committed crime on your cell phone and
they can have probable cause to go get
it rather you're convicted and died in
their convict or not as long as they
have probable cause to get it then get
it
don't you think they could do that same
thing with documents maybe even if
they're your documents yeah i mean he
probably he doesn't own them but if you
did let's hypothetically say you own
documents like you owned a cell phone
and you committed crime with those
documents
couldn't you go get those doc even
though
yeah i'm just saying i'm just saying
let's listen to um the mypelo nazi
mustache mussolini talk about how
they took his cell phone and we go
through a hardy's drive-through
around the back and we're just about
going through we pulled through the
drive-through to take the order everyone
knows how a drive-through works by i
don't know actually up until this point
i didn't know how drive-thru worked but
thank you mike lindell
i mean he literally he literally is
telling us how if i could drive through
works in this story like yeah everyone
everyone pretty much knows how a [ __ ]
driver works mike what are you talking
about why are you explaining this isn't
1940. in case you didn't know right this
is so there's a there's a line that's
painted it goes around right the
building there's some doors that you can
walk through but there's these main two
windows typically that you'll go and
talk about there's some window yeah and
a food window see and the other thing
too is they got to be on a certain side
of the building right so that way you
the driver because you're on you're
obviously let me explain how
how we drive on a certain side of the
cut jesus christ this guy let's listen
we pull up and she says pull ahead
you know because they had to make the
order part of it wasn't done yeah no
[ __ ] ahead
and a car comes perpendicular and parks
like a little ways in front of us
tonight and i've been around the block
and i said to my boy
he's been around the block so much he
knows what driver works i was going to
say yeah he he's been around the block
that has the drive-through he's been
around the drive-through he knows how
this works he puts the order in she had
to go away and put up the order and then
we moved forward this is the kind of
content you expect from lindell tv
explaining how
the drive-through works okay so he's got
a little time now so he's in the
drive-through yeah that's what he could
have said yeah i was in in the driver
drive-through
and the car
cuts in front of me now we're at that
part of the story jesus mike
stop doing crack crack is bad crack is
whack buddy i said
um that's either a bad guy
or it's it's fbi
okay so it's either a it's either a bad
guy game or a good guy yeah is is that
what he's saying i mean
is there any other there's no i mean
there's trouble there there is no other
it's either the person who wants to
commit some crime because maybe i did
something maybe i owe my dealer money
who knows right or it's the people that
are you know
supporting justice and democracy the
good guys the ones who are fighting to
make sure that people don't break the
rules or the laws or try to i don't know
invalidate an election and overthrow a
government just thinking
just cooing a little bit yeah just i
don't know just small i don't know small
little coup yeah oh my god i i said that
straight up and we go through a hardy's
drive-through straight up man straight
up he said it straight up and he was
like and i told him it's like that
person that tells you a joke and you're
like hey it was it's this is so funny
this is such a funny joke and then
they're like oh you just had to be there
you know and you're like uh i don't know
if it's that funny if you have to tell
me it's a funny joke before you tell me
to joke
then it might not be so funny right
right well so he had his phone seized
but gabe there's more there's a lot
deeper stuff to this story yes because
of why he got his phone right it's
probably the most important part because
this spans back not just
to
the coup on january 6. this wraps all
the way up to last year and we've made
fun of it several times a cyber
symposium i think there's a few
important things here number one who
financed this cyber symposium yeah
supposedly
supposedly lindell had put in at the
time
15 million dollars
for that piece of [ __ ] yeah did you
watch some of that i mean we're gonna
watch i did yeah yeah i remember
watching that day yeah i don't know dude
i don't know where he's getting this
money but he throws it all the pillow
money
but i got to imagine it's got to be
pillow money
what are we doing sitting here talking
to microphones we need to start a
pelican this is crazy it's crazy well
he gives a cyber symposium but there's a
lady who shows up there
and this is really i think why they've
taken this cell phone
and because man this gets really thick
and the reason why it gets really thick
is because
not only was mike lindell there and
spearheading that steve bannon was at
the cyber symposium he spoke there he
was there the whole time he was pushing
it on his show and all this [ __ ] how it
was gonna you know crown donald trump
president king of the united states
whatever the hell that clown thought but
here is a clip um and i think this is
super important because this person is
currently indicted
for for crimes of which mike lindell has
accused
democrats of doing am i wrong they're
insane or am i pretty spot on you're
pretty spot on with the irony yeah so
this is her name is tina peters you're
going to hear this name in the next few
months a lot yeah where you're gonna see
my pillow and tina peters you're gonna
see those two words connected like the
key words on the internet those two
things are really gonna you know kind of
[ __ ] have a baby i think um but tina
peters here she was at the cyber
symposium was she not gabe this is where
this is yeah this was august of 2021 she
was a speaker
all right at one of the panels they're
basically just sitting at a table that's
what it is it's a mind you just set the
stage
if you will uh
they're on
they're on they're on stage and they
have this like long kind of like
foldable table that's there
and they've got a big screen behind the
15 million dollar one yeah yeah a lot of
technical difficulties right they made a
movie that was like 15 or a movie that
was 15 minutes
and they played that over and over and
over again because they failed to show
any sort of proof that there was fraud
but you mean there's no evidence yeah
there is no i'm sorry i'm sorry to bust
i'm sorry to ruin it for you man there's
no evidence but in in this auditorium or
whatever it was there were a bunch of
tables
uh with very spotty people like it was
not very it was wasn't very filled at
all right and as as it went on as they
played this 15 minutes over and over and
over again they got less and less yeah
and not only that
but they did not really feed anyone they
didn't provide meals i think they had
some like complimentary like continental
breakfast type snacks or whatever mints
yeah but they're like we wasted we spent
all our money on this 15-minute video
that we're going to play again and again
and again and we're not getting
on a table and a video that's what they
jesus i don't know i mean ripoff the the
irony of having a cyber symposium but
also not knowing how to work computers
at said cyber symposium
is uh
when you're supposed to be collecting
evidence or whatever they were doing
when you're like oh we got all this
fraud
now tina peter's here she doesn't know
how to work computers she even had to
steal
allegedly steal a badge
and to get some information off a voting
machine she actually tampered which is
what they accuse
everyone else of doing they actually
intentionally tampered with voting
machines she's one of them um and shh
let's just watch this and we'll talk
about it just yesterday i got an order
from the secretary of state that she was
going to invade my elections department
today and guess what when i was on a
plane to come see you kind folks and to
talk to you out there guess what they
did
they provided a search warrant and
raided my office
this sounds familiar oh i i love the
invade words yeah they invaded they
raided
also they gave you a [ __ ] heads up
right they told you we're coming
to win i why the word invade you know i
i get they want to they want to say raid
like that like i'm not against saying
you know some people like don't call it
a raid that's just playing into the
right wing like and it's a [ __ ] raid
yeah like go look up the [ __ ]
definition yeah serving a search warrant
or raiding ants come on come on you're
you're picking you're picking a picky
[ __ ] but invade like you're like you're
invading a country on the beaches or
something i don't know it's not yeah
does doesn't she look like the karen
that would yell and scream because she
got two less slices of of ham oh yeah
she yeah she i i was pretty sure that
she would be someone that would totally
throw a fish a bunch of racist [ __ ] and
throw them away oh well there's actually
more to it but we'll keep going but okay
there's actually more to that type of
reaction okay let's let's play
we don't know what they were doing in
there because for several hours they
wouldn't even let my chief deputy clerk
who is the acting clerk for mesa county
when i'm absent would not even let her
observe what the secretary of state and
dominion were doing in my office alone
for several hours in the voting room
alone who is the lady who is narrating
i don't i don't know that's our job okay
lady don't interrupt my video don't i
like how she also goes we don't know
what they were there for yes we do yeah
we know why they were there you schemed
to commit election fraud
you stole because what what is what is
the story because they're not going to
tell us here exactly what they did the
time that they committed what is
allegedly the crime that they so the
story goes like this and uh it's a it's
a [ __ ] and story let me tell you
can't make this [ __ ] up
in yeah so if we go back just a step
here the search warrant that mike
lindell got served at hardy's
it's a probe okay say that again say
that again say that again the search
warrant that mike lindell got served in
a hardy's drive-through let me be more
specific about that that is fantastic
that's great comedy that's yeah it's
because they wanted the contents of his
phone as they were part of a larger
investigation into a colorado election
security breach now tina peters is a
county clerk mesa county clerk from
colorado now in in the warrant
uh the probe is looking into conduct
involving tina peters conan james hayes
belinda nicely sandra brown
sharona bishop
mike lindell and or douglas frank among
other co-conspirators known or unknown
to the government
the reason they're looking into this is
because tina peters and the rest of the
stop the steel people
orchestrate or i guess allegedly
orchestrated a plan that involved conan
james hayes pretending to be this i.t
tech worker in order to copy the mesa
county voting machine software so wait a
minute you're saying you're saying that
they they
they lied about someone being someone
else they went in and they tampered with
these machines in order to get a copy to
give to who but it's not only that tina
peters is the person who stole the uh
the local i.t consultant's badge
whoa whoa whoa so you're saying not only
did they pose to someone but they didn't
just happen upon this badge like they
you know
they actually stole it i mean
they stole it it was i believe the
charges also are stolen identity and
impersonating someone is amongst the
she's got like 10 criminal charges three
misdemeanors and seven felonies does
this not sound good for tina peter yes
so that that is that is why well i mean
like you said you're gonna hear more and
more of her name over the next few
months because this thing is [ __ ]
bananas
right right well let's let's see what
shell she they claim here let's see if
the narrator kicks in here again
alone with no one that knew anything
about elections watching what they did
but they did do this do you is she
saying the secretary of state doesn't
know anything about elections isn't the
secretary of state the like the head
but also if you're if you if you have
the fbi searching
your office for stuff and invading
committed a crime
invading invading if you have the fbi
invading your office because you
committed a crime
i'm pretty sure they're going to send
the right people in
that no they don't need to know anything
about elections they need to know if
they're coming in to grab any computers
like tech people uh they're going to be
dusting for fingerprints they're looking
for specific documents right because
these the things that were stolen from
the dominion voting machine
were then spread online
which found its way
to the cyber symposium via mike lindell
oh wait a second so you're saying that
the information that the person who is
sitting on stage right here in the cyber
symposium the information she stole they
they kind of in some way or fashion
brought it to this thing yep and they
actually in public committed crime are
you kidding me do you really think that
manga republicans at trump lodites that
these america first nazis would do such
a thing gabe this is quite an accusation
so of course this acidity and bone
headache here that you're of all those
names that i listed that were in there
as co-conspirators the the connection
there if we connect the different the
dots here
so also it should come as no surprise
that the guy that pretended to be the
the tech right the the the tech worker
the conan james hayes
he's a conspiracy theorist whoa
and also has ties to mike lindell oh
douglas frank who was also listed in
this system
this is where he gets the
frank's speech you know i thought about
i i don't know i thought about that when
i was when i was kind of doing the
research on this but douglas frank
reportedly passed along that information
about the scheme to lindell
who was already spreading election lies
about dominion voting machines so
now you tie in the guy the woman who
planned it you tie in the guy who
pretended to be the tech worker you tie
in the guy who passed off the
information and then you tie in mike
lindell who's holding the cypher
symposium and already is going you know
as a batshit crazy conspiracy theorist
to say that the election was rigged now
you're tying all these people together
and i wouldn't be surprised if a lot of
those communications were on a cell
phone that was seized
well you know the other thing too is it
sounds like uh having a shitty uh set up
here and not preparing food and having
you know
a great symposium as opposed to the [ __ ]
since posing that threw him for 50
million seems like 15 million was spread
somewhere else possibly let's listen to
the end of this video
after several hours they allowed my
chief deputy to come in and they go oh
look at this look look see we found this
this i don't know what they did i don't
know what they did but i can tell you
that i don't trust them
oh boy this sounds very familiar it
sounds very familiar it does and it was
a year earlier
this this type of way you're saying are
you saying there's a pattern here it's
almost like when somebody like the fbi
conducts a search of a of a a place a
home or an office
they remove
a person who might be i don't know a
conflict of interest who might also have
inside knowledge who might want to i
don't know
disrupt the flow and take something when
someone's not looking because
they're not gonna let the criminals
stand in the room while they're trying
to find the crime that they committed
this is ridiculous this is ridiculous
they should always raid someone at a
hardy's i'm just saying this should be a
new law that we should pass it only
happens
and maybe in arby's maybe maybe an
arby's maybe another yes we
got where's there what is it we got the
meat we got the meat the meat
the meat um so this video here is from
the cyber symposium i'm going to play it
real quick and then we'll talk about it
on the other side
we have a problem
my lawyer my lord just called me ty
clevenger mr tychovinger
and he said
uh that i should put up a statement
and
i just learned that conan james hayes
may have taken without authorization
the actual hard drives from the mesa
county or the mesa
colorado county clerk
and he needs to produce those hard
drives immediately and return them to
the clerk
and we should stop this data review
until he produces the hard drives
this guy looks familiar gabe who is this
this guy looks for me it's almost like
he ran for congress somewhere who is
this guy yeah yeah uh in arizona oh
really yeah
you know he looks like he looks like one
of these q anon nuts he doesn't get onto
something here he does
he he does look like someone who might
run a site that would promote uh
propaganda who is this who is this
mysterious person who won't continue
because his lawyer said hey dude you're
going to be a part of crime yeah you're
going to be federally investigated
you're going to be federally banned
that is what is interesting so what we
have here for those who don't know the
guy that was on the screen that we were
showing is ron watkins okay
q anon man not vq but he's a q anon
supporter
he spreads their propaganda on his
freshman year right
and so the big thing here is he's not
listed or at least at lea at least not
on this document is not listed as a
co-conspirator
right and i don't know
if he either is aiding in the
investigation or he backed out before
[ __ ] hit the fan
because obviously he's backing out here
and very publicly like during the point
where he's supp because he was there to
to analyze this data forever which he
also did there's another clip of him
going through the data and then being
like oh you just happen to be having
technical difficulties whenever you need
to present the data like he just calls
them out during which was a hilarious
moment i can pull the clip for you but
in that moment ron watkins basically
just calls him out for being like you
guys don't have the data and every time
people ask for it you just
say oh we're gonna go to the commercial
or you have a problem but because the
data they stole
is the data that was produced in the
election results
right so so now i mean there's obviously
more underlying data but the ultimate
idea that someone tampered with the
original data and messed with the count
the vote count is ridiculous and they
know it's ridiculous because they have
the data they stole it they stole the
data that proves so that was correct do
you want to know why they knew to raid
uh or invade tina peter's office tell me
it's because of ron watkins so ron
watkins helped spread this [ __ ] all over
8-chan and whatnot and other places but
here's the thing these documents had
passwords and other names and they all
[ __ ] traced back to tina peter's
office oh jesus
so that is why they knew hey we should
go look into this because her digital
fingerprint is all over this [ __ ] well
so he spread it she got busted
mind you this all happened to the cyber
symposium so this [ __ ] is blowing up in
real time
and so uh the other video that i i sent
you really quick is him calling this out
in real time being like this is just
you guys don't have anything organized
this [ __ ] is a [ __ ] show
so that is let's watch a bit of this and
then we'll we got to move on to the
other bonus i love that mike lindell you
could do like
like the whole week you could just do
i mean we could just make this channel
mike glendale content and we would be
okay we would be certainly okay and we
would we would have plenty of content to
uh go through but let's watch ron
watkins here at the cyber symbolism tell
them they're full of [ __ ]
yeah
it's quite coincidental that the video
feed breaks and the live streaming
platforms break as soon as we start
talking about this
what's what's funny is when this was all
happening people were like live
streaming like on tic tac and [ __ ] and
saying this is all nonsense like even
the people who believed you're like this
is all [ __ ] yeah this is why mike
lindell has never really caught on
he's never really caught on his because
he's yeah he's full of i mean he's more
full of [ __ ] than the trump family yeah
i mean it is ridiculous how much but
this guy had the you know had the ear of
trump as well as he was at the white
house do you remember that yeah with
with his papers and not only his phone
he had a phone i mean he was i mean they
were all talking about martial law you
know then you got the overstock.com
what the hell is with it well let's
let's move on because those are our our
our non-winners so that kind of gives it
away but i want to move on to the
dishonorable mention here um this
[ __ ] guy this is the guy who's saying
he's totally hateable i think uh al
franken says i like ted cruz more than
uh
most of my colleagues and my colleagues
hate ted cruz is that what he says what
what is he i think that's i think that's
how it goes yeah yeah it's close to that
yeah yeah well that's close enough right
[Laughter]
basically
moral the story is
everybody hates
[ __ ] ted cruz who doesn't who doesn't
uh hate ted cruz yeah like i said
earlier so those daughters they made a
tick tock about their life under his
you know uh so let's see what's the uh
oh this is the tweet that i want um so
he the one reason why he's on bone of
the week is because of um some of the
school shootings in uval are in in texas
specifically uvalde um kimberly posted
here where this this family is sharing
a photo of their child
in a casket with him that's what that's
the phone a child-sized casket right
that ted cruz is holding there and of
course
he looks like you could hate the
[ __ ] right and just i like i
hate him i mean the attitude that i get
from him is like and you're showing me
this because
right like that's the vibe i get from
his like the the lack of like hey
like these parents if you look at body
language like i know a very basic body
language but these people are coming in
to try to they're getting somebody yeah
they're listening
and she's got his hand out
and she's consoling him on the back
because obviously this is a very
traumatic and and sad story or or
experience that they're trying to
get him to understand
and he's laid back and he's like
yeah so she's in a casket whatever which
is the [ __ ] terrible like
he said
such a [ __ ] scumbag this is almost as
scummy as [ __ ] well it's just as
gummy i mean the same kind of scum as
rudy giuliani
sang
saying oh
911 was the best day of my life like
jesus [ __ ] people but there's
something else he did he went on a floor
of the senate here's a video of this son
of a [ __ ]
after he did that here's the son of a
[ __ ]
oh you like the face the other
maybe that's all i should show what's
wish.com wannabe wolverine we're gonna
watch a bit of this because there's
actually another version this video that
i want to show that i think is more
appropriate but let's watch this version
from c-span 2.
the vivaldi shooting was the deadliest
school shooting
in texas history
before that
i was in santa
fe or yet another evil madman okay i
can't i can't take it i can't take it
because honestly he's doing the thing
where he's like oh i went and not spent
time with these families but then when
it came time to vote on a bill that
would protect children not just in texas
but all around the country from [ __ ]
people with weapons of war going in and
tearing them apart yeah
i mean it the because we've both watched
this video and it's not very long but he
goes through dramatic pause after
dramatic pause after dramatic pause and
saying it was uh uvalde it was uh you
know el paso it was here it was here it
was here and he goes through
and
in a similar fashion to sean hannity
listen out all of the crimes that trump
has been investigated for
he goes through a list of places just in
[ __ ] texas
where people have used guns to kill
other people in a mass shooting children
up to adults
right and and ted cruz used to this
moment to somehow believe that what he's
saying actually makes an argument for
we need to protect these children more
by bringing more guns in
more guns that's the end but if you
listen
if you list out all of these travesties
that happen
you're like uh maybe the problem is the
[ __ ] guns right
well someone redid this video one of our
friends here
paulie teaks
ticks and um
i think it's more appropriate senator
count chocula because he's counting
how many it's [ __ ] gross but let's
well this is a much better version let's
watch
the vivaldi shooting was the deadliest
school shooting
in texas history
before that
i was in santa fe
where yet another evil madman
killed eight students and two teachers
so he's counting the school shootings in
texas that he refuses to do anything
right to stop because he believes the
problem is he doesn't believe [ __ ] he's
not a principal [ __ ] right he's
just like the rest of these republicans
they don't believe [ __ ] it's all about
their it's all it's not about the
constituents it's about the goddamn
manufacturers about the goddamn nra
putting money in their [ __ ] pockets
winning them goddamn elections [ __ ] [ __ ]
these manga republicans [ __ ] them and
i'm sick and tired and boy this you've
all this [ __ ] really gets me going
because i got school-aged children just
like a lot of people out there and we're
sick and tired of [ __ ] people
gaslighting us telling us the only way
to keep our [ __ ] kids safe in schools
is to build big fences put locks on the
doors and have more guns and we know
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ] that's all
[ __ ] do your [ __ ] job and
do the job of government and regulate
these things to keep these [ __ ] kids
safe and oh by the way [ __ ] ted cruz
exactly
buck take cruise okay let's move on to
the alpha cuck here almost as hateable
almost almost
almost i gotta eat really this russian
asset here is almost as hate about this
guy
no rand paul who
just another person who uh who supports
the insurrection
you know you know the nice part about um
rand paul
is that you can hate him but for some
odd reason
some odd reason you love his neighbor
and you don't even know his neighbor and
you love it i don't know the neighbors i
don't know the neighbor's name i don't
know where he lives exactly but i will
say
that there's a lot of people
based on what rand paul does or rather
lack thereof when it comes to
constituents that people be like yeah i
like that guy i would move the next day
that [ __ ] guy you know if you had one
wish to grant or genie had one wish for
you i don't know maybe you would want
to be rand paul's neighbor that would be
the one wish that you would you would
wish for now this is this is in a uh uh
a senate meeting of course fouchy's here
uh rand paul's archenemy dr fauci um and
the best actual and actual doctor right
an actual doctor give me one rand paul
right not one that made up her
certificate and tried to pass it off as
a made up of what i should certificate a
certificate
he believes i don't know did he print it
off a printer and then i mean
not to take it back to michael lindell
but if you look if you go if anyone
watching this goes back to when we're
showing clips of michael and dello if
you look over his shoulder he's got a
certificate of excellence for michael j
lindell who gave it to him probably him
and he probably printed off online or
got it from trump university i don't
[ __ ] know i'm definitely going to get
one of those i need one of those a a
certificate of excellence right back
here you got to get it for michael j
lindell not for tonight yeah well no
absolutely it's got to be for him who
else would
print their own [ __ ] certificate of
excellence maybe rand paul let's watch
she's had the flu for 14 days should she
get a flu shot well no if she got the
flu for 14 days she's as protected as
anybody can be because the best
vaccination is to get infected yourself
and so if she if she really has the flu
if she really has the flu
she definitely doesn't need a flu
vaccine
if she really has the flu she should not
get it again she doesn't need it because
the it's the best it's the most potent
vaccination is getting infected yourself
okay so this is a video that anthony
fauci did on c-span years ago he was
asked a question on the show he
responded to the question on the show he
actually the the answer that he gives is
not is not opposite of what he says now
it's actually the exact same thing that
he says now they just try to use this to
twist this like in threads and [ __ ] and
they try to get you all uh you know
discombobulated which is what rand paul
tries to do here he is unsuccessful um
with anthony fountain watch this
this is he thinks he's got him by the
way yeah oh look at him
on my ipad i [ __ ] got you dude gotcha
[ __ ] because really honestly if rand
paul really thought he would get anthony
fauncy with this [ __ ] clip he'd have
done this a long time ago but he's
running at it he's running out of sticks
here he's got to go all the way to the
shitty internet to get these to get
these tactics let's watch it's an
ongoing question and you know we've had
ever evolving opinions from you dr
falchi
currently anabolic that's because that's
how
never mind yeah you wouldn't you
wouldn't know what the word science
and medical science means so i'm not you
know going there virus or you know
[ __ ] idiot mutations from that virus
what a dumbass body surveys show that uh
80 of children approximately 80 percent
of children have had covid and yet there
are no guidelines coming from you or
anybody in the government to take into
account their naturally acquired
immunity
you seem quite certain of yourself in
2004 but in 2022 there's a lot less
certainty
one of the things that we also know
again i want to point something out here
i want to point something out the reason
why dr fauci has more certainty about
the [ __ ] flu in 2004 is because the
flu was a couple years old by then yeah
like this idea that we didn't know that
dr fauci wouldn't know a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ]
information and science and medical and
you know there's tons of medical studies
on the flu influenza
then covid or even monkey which is also
you know and for people yeah it's like
you know we've had influenza for years
now
and the reason that it's not as deadly
as say i don't know a novel virus called
covid19
is because it's not a [ __ ] novel
virus it's not the first strain of it
that's protecting people that nobody or
the second third or fourth right exactly
it's been around for a hundred years
it's been around for a while it is it is
a lesson version yes it can kill people
and yes it can be very sickening or
deadly to people but
that is years
years of it going through different
strains and mutations and you know
knowing more about i mean we're even a
situation now where i think most people
feel comfortable um with covet at this
point i mean well we have to be you know
right well i mean you get facts i mean
we're going to live with it like we live
with the flu right right so that's just
what we're going to do that's called i
don't know
science
we're not going to be able to get rid of
these things i mean hopefully someday
there may be technology that allows us
to do that but at this point in history
we do not have the capability to
eradicate things like the flu or covet
but rand paul seems to not
understand anything so i know he's not a
doctor so you won't get it he's a [ __ ]
anyone is not a doctor actually studies
infectious diseases
who is who is is it the guy that he's
questioning let's see
after looking at this for two to three
years uh
is that the mortality uh from covet is
very similar if not less than than
influenza nope not even so when we look
at this we wonder
you know why you seem to really know
don't wonder at all technology back in
2004 and how you or why you seem to
reject it now because it's two different
things
i don't reject basic immunology senator
and i have never denied
that there is importance of the
protection
following infection
however
as we have said many times
and has has been
validated by the authorization
of the by the fda through their
committee and the recommendation
by the cdc through their committee
that a vaccination
following infection gives an added extra
boost and that film that you showed
is really taken out of context i believe
that was when someone called in
who had had a reaction
to a vaccine and asked me
through a telephone
in the interview
if they should
get vaccinated again so it was in the
context of someone
who had a reaction
so in other words she got the flu
from getting the vaccine and she wanted
to know if she should go get another
vaccine and he's saying in the clip no
you've already got the flu wait wait
wait wait so you mean
that a republican took a clip
and took it out of context without
adding
the phone call the question the person
who it was about the specific situation
what i'm what i'm saying here is this
guy that you see on the screen here yeah
yeah he's a vile piece of [ __ ] oh yeah
he knows he's [ __ ] he knows what he's
doing i actually don't think rand paul's
stupid i actually don't think rand paul
does which makes this worse right
exactly he
he knows he knows the basics here and
this video really shows it and and fauci
dunks him in the [ __ ] garbage
here let's watch the you decry and
people decry vaccine hesitancy it's
coming from the gobbledygook that you
give us you're not paying attention to
the sides the very basic science is that
previous infection provides a level of
immunity if you ignore that in your
studies if you don't present that in
your committees you're not being
truthful or honest with us
senator if i might respond i have never
ever denied fundamental
immunology in fact
i wrote the chapter in the textbook of
medicine is it anything fundamentally
any of the guys
any of the guidelines for vaccines
he wrote the [ __ ] book yeah he
wrote he's like uh
look yeah i get that you may have read
the wikipedia on this but i [ __ ]
wrote it right i [ __ ] wrote the
actual textbook that people learn from
in medical school not that you would
have learned this in your non-medical
school degree
but listen up bucko
like the idea that it's always rand paul
versus like dr fauci is like look dude
i'm just trying to save lives and you're
over here trying to make my job harder
like i'm trying to retire and you're
trying to pull me back into the [ __ ]
game
of this hey you said this you did this
and fauci's like i didn't say that you
took it out of context i didn't do that
and again this was before a flu that
already existed
not one that would already had a deadly
virus that was attacking the world
the [ __ ] world a pandemic and the
reason we had to shut down was because
or the reason that they said yeah you
should get the vaccine because we had no
protection we had no immunity
it was just going up against this thing
without any shield any armor
well now i want to go to
speaking of um
pieces of garbage because
boy you guys voted overwhelmingly yeah
this was a holy [ __ ] it was like a
[ __ ] it was a blow gate out of the
gate i really thought mike lindell had a
chance
but after what lindsey graham said
and how he put it now we have some other
video footage here because um we have
lindsey graham's original statement and
and uh i'm just going to play a bit of
that and then we also have
um
his response i think on jessie warner's
show but then he's got um
a video
also um somewhere else so let's watch
this one here this is the press
conference that he gave and gabe he's
talking about a national ban on abortion
now republicans are in big trouble here
politically because americans are on to
them because they want to take people's
freedom away from them but listen to
what listen to what the bone end of the
week says here in this in this little
clip so we're going to have an election
in 2022
if we take back the house and the senate
i can assure you we'll have a vote on
our bill
if the democrats are in charge i don't
know if we'll ever ever vote on our bill
good so what he's saying what he's
saying is you got a choice america you
can vote for republicans and they'll
take away your freedoms or you can vote
for democrats and they'll actually
codify
your freedoms those are your choices so
what do you want you like you like your
rights right you don't like your rights
right right right well i mean this is
pretty easy stuff this is why which
again like the [ __ ] you know we've
got we've got i think it's blake masters
and some other people that have taken
off
their abortion stances from their
website because they've seen they
thought this leak was going to help them
they thought this leak and then the
decision from the supreme court was
going to show hey you know what we're
doing what the people wanted
oh surprise surprise turns out that a
very few do not represent the majority
of people who said get the [ __ ] out of
my body
right well
americans in general i don't care if
you're republican democrat independent
christian not whatever the [ __ ] you are
out there if you're in this country you
value your freedom and and you value the
ability for people not to tell you what
the [ __ ] to do especially someone who
looks like lindsey graham but uh jamie
raskin
he goes he takes to the house floor and
he burns lindsey graham's house down um
watch what this is a fantastic piece of
footage watch jamie raskin take lindsey
graham out behind the woodshed and spank
his little ass here
yesterday senator lindsey graham
introduced legislation for a national
criminal ban on abortion
but of course the the so-called pro-life
forces want to go further in the states
uh and ban it completely a lot of them
don't even want to allow exceptions for
rape or incest i thought our colleagues
were going to explain what their
position really is i would invite them
to do so as long as they don't want to
talk about the legislation before us
today why don't they tell us what their
position on abortion is because america
wants to know i think their position
has changed somewhat they're singing a
somewhat different tune since the people
of kansas by 20 points
destroyed their anti-choice agenda and
explained to them in numerical terms
that the people of america are on the
side of freedom so there's jamie raskin
you know the best jamie raskin do you
know the best jamie raskin is jamie this
james you're asking dark
dark jamie raskin baby we should i don't
know maybe we should clip it i don't
know but he brings up a great point
right he says that they were totally
fine with it and then we saw what
happened in kansas and when the pastor
was another like
republicans also
learned
that oh actually maybe people don't want
us to take away these rights or rather
they didn't like the fact that we
uh we took away roe v wade and we
haven't codified it
it's
the thing that is very telling here
is that they now said well okay we were
gonna give it to the states and we
thought the states were gonna rule the
way that we wanted but now turns out
when you give the power to the people
and the right to vote to actually make
their voice heard to say uh we don't
want you to do that then they say okay
you know what
you didn't earn this so now we're you
know now we're going to get to everyone
well it's same thing in michigan
michigan's supreme court put the um put
the referendum on the ballot the
republicans were working hard to take it
off the bout because they know the same
thing right is going to happen in
michigan to happen in kansas and state
by state they may codify this right and
it may take the right away from
republicans to oppress the rights of
other people which is not
liberty i say it every show in the front
of the um it's in the intro yeah the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not liberty now lindsey graham
apparently is party backing you know
backing backstepping from his statements
here on on this guy's show let's watch
what these two traders are saying on
trader tv news network i know in north
korea
we all agree on that wait a minute now
listen i'm not going to sit on the
sidelines and let america become that
kind of nation no one's saying you need
to sit on the sidelines but yesterday
wasn't the day to do that yesterday was
the day they lost all momentum when this
inflation thing punched him right in the
face and you gave him an out a lot of
people don't like that you could have
done it
even jesse waters knows what happens
here right they're talking about
inflation they're talking about the
market which is all [ __ ] and here's
the reason why it's [ __ ] is because
three months ago they were yelling and
screaming and jim jordan he's still
[ __ ] tweeting about gas prices being
eight dollars and they're not eight
dollars they're [ __ ] lying pieces of
[ __ ] let me tell you something if you
want to know the truth don't believe
anything republicans say or or
listen to what they say and then just
think the opposite right right well
because that's the thing is that
yesterday the market the market came
down because inflation didn't cool off
as much as they wanted but it is cooling
which is the whole point
so but the market reacted to it not
cooling as much as they projected it to
because that's what happens in business
and capital and investment is they like
to plan things slow down tony can you
slow your roll yeah yeah well you know
just
slower
[ __ ] republicans is that oh yeah no i
got that okay okay well let's let's
continue here with lady g and jessie
waters jesse waters giving him a
spanking other day
just like you could have delayed the
whole press conference like joe should
have delayed that stupid party it feels
like to me that lindsey graham has the
energy when someone finds out that he
has a certain app on his phone that he's
run wandering around washington using
you know what i'm saying hey you know
what i'm saying i'm picking up what
you're putting down okay well let's
continue uh so i take issue i don't
think i don't think there's a bad day to
stand up from the unborn what am i
trying to say that america needs to have
a policy that makes us a civilized
nation it would bother me that if a
baby's aborted at 38 weeks in california
new york what am i proposing for our
country that at 15 weeks when the baby
can feel pain you provide anesthesia
okay i can't listen to the lies anymore
i can't do the lies anymore this whole
15 week 14 week 18 week 16 week they
keep you know they keep moving around
and they're like this is a [ __ ] old
dude telling people what the [ __ ] what
what is not anything they would ever
experience yeah i i would never sit and
lecture people on weeks or when the baby
or fetus or the uterus i don't have one
i don't know
right stop stop telling other
[ __ ] [ __ ] you don't know
anything about lindsey graham rand paul
ted cruz mike lindell rudy giuliani shut
the [ __ ] up i mean i guess that's why
he's the bone end of the week yeah that
would be why and again you know as we'll
see in a moment he really
took off yeah well let's get let's do
this
let's give lady g
his due
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh lindsey graham you are a piece of
[ __ ] and you are the bonehead of the
week i love this picture that you have
of him oh yeah that's uh i forget what i
forget what interview he did
but it's from a clip where he like licks
he just like like oh god the tongue
right now as we look at it reminds me of
the tongue that was in that dehydrated
dinosaur from uh jurassic park right
where they go see it they're like oh
yeah when when uh when it's hanging out
yeah would you have a big pile of [ __ ]
that's a big pile of [ __ ] that's the
moment in the movie that's the lindsay
graham moment that's the lindsey graham
that is the tongue that because you see
the tongue and then he goes oh that's a
big pile of [ __ ] and boy lindsay you are
a big pile of [ __ ] everyone thanks for
joining us here on the bone end of the
week every single friday do not forget
the tony michaels podcast every single
friday on the minus touch network and
the tony michaels podcast stuck in our
friday friday friday bone end of the
week come watch it on our channel at the
tony michael's pod don't forget to
subscribe there subscribe if you're
watching this on the midas touch network
and go follow us on the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends at tony michael's
pod to vote for bonehead of the week
what a great week gabe
everyone have a great weekend
have a great great weekend we will talk
to you soon
this has been this edition of bonehead
of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week
that was that was fantastic yeah
best best segment there is i'm glad you
there's nothing better i'm glad you
could get your ai self here i know and
you know as long as nobody experienced
any glitches on my end i think i think
the ai bot is working pretty good
everyone knows that we recorded this
ahead of time because we did the bone
into the week pull earlier in the week
now thanks thanks for sticking around
with us this week it's been a great week
a lot of news um and bonehead is always
our our our favorite segment and that's
why we do it at the very end have an
explanation point on the week and don't
forget don't forget to subscribe right
here at the tony michaels pod
every single week monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and simon casting
from facebook also don't forget man we
got these
shirts
summoning the democratic powers it is
awesome i you know the red really
because they freaked out about the red i
was like we got to do a red design red i
don't know the red really brings out his
eyes it does
he's got great eyes in this design so go
pick up your dark brandon merch t-shirts
hoodies coffee cups stickers
go to store dot d tonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com and get your
favorite
dark brandon merch with our exclusive
design
also don't forget to download every
single episode on apple spotify google
leave us a great review while you're
there subscribing
gabe it's been a great week thanks for
kind of joining us here on friday even
though it's
not friday but it is for the yeah the
audience the audience
for them when they see this so everyone
have a great weekend
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal barn head ass